I can
Ekans hates you may know story to tell
you know once was a little boy who cried
wolf to work we go to that dude I knew
to president one day I'll have you know
not anymore though he doesn't like me
I'll have you know that I also know the
President and I know I'm currently and
not one day as you say if that day ever
was what that day wasn't you're not a
fried my name big tooth McGee well if
you take the square root of 723 and you
divide that by 45 you'll get how many
dates I've been on
I just adorable are you did you tit do I
[Music]
[Laughter]
care for
[Music]
[Applause]
well my mama says I'm handsome I now are
really mad at me I was without my tiny
mouth huh time with hanging out people
who paralyzed from I hate him for me
gurgle angle sin abutters now it's the
dragon-sickness I tell ya I've seen it
before he consumed his grandfather it'll
consume him too I'm a dwarf
everyone's gonna be so happy away ha ha
ha
you touch my tralala oh my ding ding
dong I'm dreaming
see Christmas just like the ones I you
know my god this is a nightmare
damn